bonjour bonjour l'heure du magasin je
défaites au Sony dans ce magasin Best
boy de la rue Sainte-Catherine les
clients se comptent par centaines durant
leur du Midi tu travailles juste à côté
alors c'est pratique pour moi je suis sa
mère fait que je surveille ce qu'elle va
acheter ouais faut pas qu'elle fasse des
folies fous malgré la crainte d'une
récession qui se profile à l'horizon les
clients n'hésitent pas à ouvrir leur
portefeuille
on achète des cadeaux de Noël pour la
famille des écouteurs pour écouter la
télévision sans déranger mon mari je
dirais téléviseur les jeux vidéos
souvent les tendances Rémi Semoun et
directeur chez Best Buy il planifie
cette journée depuis plusieurs semaines
pour laquelle plus d'une centaine
d'employés sont mises à contribution
l'inventaire aussi commence à rentrer
depuis à peu près un mois je vous dis
les détaillants ont connu l'an dernier
des problèmes d'inventaires il assure
que la situation s'est largement réglé
cette année
ce client n'aura toutefois pas réussi à
mettre la main sur la Playstation 5
qu'il convoitait il y a ni la console
mais il y a les jeux donc je les ai
achetés parce que par exemple FIFA il
est à -50% et c'est quand même une
sacrée aubaine combien il est Canadiens
prévoient-ils dépenser cette année pour
la période des fêtes selon le Conseil
canadien du commerce de détails en
moyenne
790$ au Canada
590 dollars au Québec bref tout autant
que l'an dernier 60% des gens ont dit
qu'il serait davantage cette année à la
à l'affût des rabais donc c'est beaucoup
beaucoup plus de gens que par le passé
le président du Conseil Canadien
remarque du même coup que le vendredi
fou a détrôné le Boxing Day du 26
décembre aujourd'hui c'est la journée où
est-ce que les gens vont acheter
justement le plus possible de souliers
plus possible de vêtements
et la facture grimpe rapidement observe
la Stan gérante de cette boutique Foot
Locker entre un minimum je dirais ça
puis des fois ça peut aller dans les
mails alors que de nombreux Canadiens se
sert la ceinture en cette période
d'incertitude d'autres dépensent sans
compter ici à Yacine